Well, yeah, so yeah, we,
so we have this thing called own cloves day.
Well,
where we have like one day in like the term or something where we could just
come in in our own clothes and
I was speaking to Sydney and apparently like she was in her high school.
They didn't have school uniform. No. Yeah. They,
they just American high schools don't wear uniforms.
Big brain because you always wear the same every day. Yeah. Right. It's great.
You have to worry about like, Oh,
I want the same t-shirt for three days in a row because yeah. Yeah. That's,
that's, that's a big reason why.
I didn't give a about fashion until like later in life.
Was just because most, most days of the year I was wearing a school uniform.
You know what I mean? Although I say that the, the fashion,
like whoever designed my school uniform,
like deserves a slap because like,
I guess so in our high school, like you have to wear,
there's a set piece that you have to wear from when your seventh grade to 10th
grade. And then when you enter at 11th and 12th grade, you'll like senior.
So you get to wear like a, a senior blazer and like cans and like that.
The senior uniform is fine. It looks dope as.
It's basically just a suit essentially.
But the junior uniform is a, is a little,
because for one, uh, everyone has to wear shorts
because you know, it's hot, it's hot most of the year in Australia.
So you wear shorts, but then on top of that, you have to wear long socks.
Like, yeah. I'm talking like up to like the, like me long socks,
like anime, like anime, like these like gray, like knitted,
like long someone had a fetish. Someone had a face. So like,
basically there's just these like seventh to 10th grade kids running around,
basically just only showing their knee was,
was your school run by like Herbert the pervert? I don't know. I mean,
I'm not going to give it to that one, but yeah. So I hated that.
But, and of course, because you know, I went to a private school.
If you didn't weigh your thing properly, right. punished for it.
Look at this private school, see your shins.
You're going to get a slap for that. You pull your socks up. I was like, okay.
Yeah. So in, in British schools, it goes secondary school, no primary school,
then secondary school, then sixth form.
Which is part of secondary school. You normally.
Kind of, kind of. So like our high school is secondary school when 64.
Like put together, that's like the set of the skip from two to six and then,
okay. So, so it's called secondary school.
Cause it's the second school that you go to. So,
and then you start at age 12 and then you can, Oh, it's mandatory now. Right.
You have to do six form now. Right. So used to be, you could leave at 16. Yeah.
And you could go and you know, you could go and work. Uh,
and then it was always an optional, if you want to go to university,
you have to stay an extra two years. Yeah. Which normally has about,
at least in my school, like half the kids left.
Yeah. 16. Yeah. So in Australia that would be junior high and senior.
So it's like we have high school.
So we have primary school and high school as well in high schools from seventh
grade to 12th.
Grade, seventh grade when you're like age 12.
13. And then you can leave at year 10, which is like,
I guess the end of secondary for you guys.
And then the last two years is senior.
And, and that's like 16 to 18 and that's 16 to 18. Yes.
That's what it's like in the UK. Um, and like when I was in sixth form,
so I was in my last two years, uh,
they try to introduce to the school like blazes, cause we didn't have lasers.
We had blazes, we're a public school. So blazers were like, Oh,
we'll get a load of these people.
And there's like outrage because they were like, because right.
Here's the thing, the school uniform,
you can only buy from like a special place. Right. You can just get on Amazon.
Right. And they were charging like 70 pounds for the blazer.
And obviously this is a public school and 70 pounds, like a hundred bucks.
And for some parents it's like way too box. So they were like, what the? No,
we don't want to blaze up. There was a whole like outrage about it.
And then eventually they were like, fine, fine. Okay.
Because the older kids are leaving, they don't need to web blazes.
So I didn't have to web once. It was very fun.
It wasn't mandatory. So mandatory is your school uniform. And uh,
I was at a time. So we in, in England, we call it sixth form college as well,
which gets a bit confusing. When we say, when we say college,
we mean sixth form, but you can go to college. You can go to actual colleges.
Yeah.
What college is in college college in the UK is a one or two years. Right.
Of like a specialized thing that you can then use to.
Well, we call that something different. No, we have,
we have to college that's college, but we have six form college.
And then we have whatever preschool university is that is that called college as
well. Leave those two, the same institutions, if I'm correct,
because in Australia we don't even call it college. Like we don't use that word.
Well, colleges, that's why I'm an American say, are you going to college?
You're like, yeah.
No, no, no, no. We're going to universe. We're going to use,
it's like the Winnie phooey college university,
because college is something entirely different separately. Yeah. Yeah. It is.
Yeah. I mean, anyway. Yeah, they were outraged.
So half the half the school didn't have to web lasers and half the young kids
did, you could just be like, you know, Hey,
look at this little ten-year-old right. He's a little blazer.
No, we loved the blades. Like the blaze was the best bit.
Cause we were because you weren't supposed to,
but the teachers got so done with it that you could just wear hoodies over your
school uniform.
They must have like where the rules in this school, man, it's in the winter.
Right? Like if it was just a regular, just white t-shirt underneath,
it'd be way too cold. Yeah. So sometimes you'd have like,
you'd have to wear the blazer just to stay warm.
Because the other option we had was this,
like our school colors were black and red. So we had this,
like the evil school and like it was black and red. So like we had this, like,
if you didn't want to wear a blazer, you have to wear this bright red,
white light, like woolen, like sweat or something like that. It was green,
green. But yeah. Yeah. I know the exact color houses, like.
Bright.
Red, like, like the reddest red you can think of.
So you just stick out in a crowd. Right? I mean,
at least you had like pretty colors. Ours was like drab purple. Yeah. But like,
yeah. But the problem was is that because it was like a Wolf thing.
It was so ichi. Like it doesn't matter how many times you wash that.
You're just like, I'm warm, but this.
So people were just like, it.
I'm just going to like spend the a hundred bucks on the blazer because I don't
want to wear this. Her like grandma's sweat a.
Cause I remember in my sixth form, I knew,
I knew I was a grown up in my sixth form.
W we w we went to like the coolest thing for them because they let us wear our
own clothes. And this, this,
this was the big thing we were allowed to call our teachers by their first name.
Oh. That was like bringing up to the next level, man.
Like we could only do that, but like, it was, it was a kg gamble.
Every time it was like, do I call you this? The Smith?
Or do I just call you James.
One student did that in my class. And the immediate, like,
what the do you call me?
[Inaudible].
Especially towards the female teachers. It's like, it's like, uh, excuse me,
Margaret. And she's just like, what the? Yeah.
Holy.
Bro. I remember I'm sorry. I just had this like flashback to something.
I remember. I did like, uh, so we had to do a presentation during,
what do you have registration in Australia for one where you basically,
when you get to school, you do separate class,
like registration to say that you're here and you know, you've, you've arrived.
Like orientation, stuff like that. I guess. Yeah. Orientation, maybe Americans.
It's like a quick 15 minute thing where everyone just goes and stuff.
Oh yeah. I forgot what that was called. It was called like a home home,
home, home class, home. We had a Welsh homeroom.
That's American. Now we call it a home.
Well, we, my school would call it registration in English,
but I can get a wash word for it. That extra call. Right. there.
But we just do like a short presentation, um, between like,
it would always be one of the students presentation each day.
Would you have to do a presentation on what you learned?
There's some perfectly pretentious.
Yeah. You can do a quick presentation about something you've learned that day.
Oh my God. That was awful. So I was like, I was like 14, right?
I w we all hated it. And this teacher was horrible. So my, my, my,
my best mate in school had a really bad like, stuttering problem.
You got a lot better now, but everyone like loved this guy.
Cause everyone's wanted to see him do well.
And this one teacher was so rude to him about his stutter. And I was so,
and everyone was like, yo, all my homies hate that teacher.
So we were all just like, we all took it in turns,
like trying to see how much we control in these presentations.
I did a pro game of move. I was like, you know what?
I'm gonna present nine 11 conspiracy theory.
I, you know, I, you dog.
And I did ask, I think I got the teacher to believe me, but I'm not like,
so I came in, I was like moon lending fake. But what,
what is the biggest conspiracy theory like this? Like,
like Steve jobs in a tattoo. I was like, listen, look at this.
I did the wing dings thing with, uh, with the flight. And I was like, look,
it's two towers. And the star of Israel, I rest my case. I never,
almost like, everyone's like no way, because I was like 14,
that shisha wasn't there. It wasn't that they were like, what the?
This is insane. Wow. It was just so funny.
Cause I never got told off for that. Really? No, I think,
I think for some reason I think they thought I was super genuine about my belief
of this, but
he just said it with enough conviction that they were still like,
he must be right. It must be walking. Right.
It wasn't just like the Winn-Dixie I think said a bunch of other stuff,
but that was like the,
the big piece of evidence where I was like the wind Microsoft planned nine
to the, I do not know how I got away with doing that because that is bad
hell. We didn't do anything during late home. Right.
I, I feel like they,
the school just implemented that to give the teachers their 15 minute smoke
break before the beginning. Right? Like.
It was one of those teachers, the one who did it.
Cause we didn't have any lessons with that, but she was always that one.
He goes like, you should be constantly learning and advancing yourself though.
I want to play modern warfare too at home. prepare.
Homeroom was just coming together and just getting on our iPhone stories and
playing doodle jump together like that. That was the only thing we did.
Wondering if we, I don't think I even had like a homeroom segment or session.
Segment of segment of the school day or whatever you can think of life and
episodes. Season one, season two.
Oh my God. I didn't have anything like that.